spider-man has come into that avengers
game but with a catch
also your ps4 controllers can work with
ps5 consoles
but also the catch and xbox is getting a
new store i'm current davina this is
save state for august 3rd
it's monday welcome to the week glad to
have you
[Music]
okay so spider-man is coming to the
avengers game in 2021
post launch his gameplay will focus on
acrobatic exploration and combat he'll
also
have gear built by other heroes like web
shooters built by
ant-man now we haven't seen what the
suit looks like but it's going to be
based on the original work by steve
ditko and the reworked version by john
romita senior
but with a catch his exclusive only to
the ps4 and ps5 versions because sony's
got their sticky mitts all over the
sticky hand
webb slinnin slingin spider man
so i sorry xbox users are gonna have to
live
vicariously in the shadows like you've
had to with insomniac spider-man so
yeah while we're on the topic of sony
you're gonna be able to use your
playstation 4 controllers
with the ps5 however you're only going
to be able to use them with ps4 games
they will not work
with ps5 games confirmed by a sony on
the playstation blog
ps5 games won't work with dual shock 4
because ps5 games
quote should take advantage of the new
capabilities and features we're bringing
to the platform
including the features of dual sense
wireless controller
however the dualshock 4 and third party
ps4 controllers
will work with backwards compatible ps4
games on the ps5
and in response to this the xbox uk
twitter account
reminded everyone that the xbox one
controller will work with the xbox
series x
things are getting spicy which segues
perfectly to the next story because a
new version of the microsoft store
is coming to the xbox one this is a
total rebuild that focuses on loading
speeds ease of use and safety functions
official xbox post claims that the store
will be twice as fast as the old one and
will launch
in just two seconds the wishlist cart
and curation tools have been updated to
let you easily scan your potential
purchases
xbox insiders will see the store first
as the preview will start rolling out at
a staggered rate on wednesday the 5th
that's it for news but we still have one
order of business the gamespot merch
store yes that's right
we have our own merch tour with
skateboards and t-shirts and hoodies and
face masks
all sorts of wonderful jazz and all the
proceeds
to the end of august we'll be going to
both black lives matter and kobit 19
relief so if you have the chance if
you're willing check it out take a look
a link will be in the description
below okay that's it you can hear about
everything i just talked about
and more by going to gamespot.com also
it's lucy james's birthday she's a host
here on gamespot you should wish her a
happy birthday if you have a chance
follow her tweet at her at lucy james
games
say happy birthday from from you or me
anyways i'm curt davina this was save
state till next time
be well see
you